- [Kelly] Okay, wait.
Speaking of young Niall though,
I wanna see the... Let's show this photo.
(audience cheering)
Come on.
First of all, I love that you look
like you're selling insurance
at the age of two.
(Niall laughing)
You were in a full-on suit.
Look at that cardigan. I love it.
- I'm Niall from State Farm.
- Yeah, that's amazing.
You love cardigans now though.
- Yeah.
- I love your style
by the way.
- Thank you.
- I say it every time you show up.
- You do actually, yeah.
- You look so cool,
like every time you show up.
(audience clapping)
- Thanks.
- How many cardigans
do you own?
- That's why I love
working with her, by the way.
- No, he does.
He looks so cool.
He walks into the room
and I'm just like, what?
Like, yeah, you're just like
screaming. It's annoying.
But how many cardigans do you own?
- A lot. (chuckles)
I didn't realize how many I'd like owned
until my fans started
pointing it out to me.
- "We wanna see your cardigan collection,
'cause you clearly have a lot."
- When they ask that,
that means you definitely have a lot.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, honestly.
I didn't realize it.
You know, it's that time
in year, it's winter,
you're kind of always just
like, just throw it on.
And then I opened up the
closet and had a look
and I was like, "Oh, I have a lot."
(audience laughing)
- I think we have a video
of your cardigan collection.
So I wanna show this.
- [Niall] I only have
like one, two, three...
7,645 million.
God, I love cardigans.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- I love how you say, "tree."
- Tree.
- One
- [Both] Two, tree.
- Yeah, I remember saying that
and going, "Oh, I'm gonna
get ripped for that one."
- For tree?
- The old Irish accent. Tree.
- Tree.
- Yeah, I've tried
to like start pronouncing my T-H,
- [Kelly] Don't do it.
- T-H's, T-H's, T-H's
- Work on that.
- Yeah.